he's Washington Redskins quarterback
Josh Norman back here on the Rich Eisen
show how you been Josh Aires is going on
man I'm doing Iraq where wherever I
found you tell me what's going on in the
Monday of Memorial Day Week with Josh
Norman what do you got for me Performa
Morial day well come back home funeral
oh no I'm sorry yeah oh yeah Cash's that
you know visitors church by often wonder
friends of the family past week on
charity so they had a very informal
Monday I came out here and you know show
huh oh I'm gratitude too
so well out here I offer my condolences
to you and everybody who knew this
pastor and so what he what do you do at
this part of the year is I guess my way
of asking outside of attending to
anything like that well uh I just got
back from Paris I was over there with
the soccer club Paris and romantic sheet
okay um yeah I was over there for the
weekend they had their final match of
the year and I went out in Soma and I
they brought me out that way and it was
a joy you know I had a good time
do you speak French it do you speak
French Josh oh yeah you know I spoke to
another high school and I dropped off
from it so I don't know what it did I
can like pick up when I get back over
there I could pick up on some of the
words they saying like the whole bunch
you'll see by suitably is a couple of
things because of all the things I pick
up all I can say over there so well
sometimes sometimes watching you in a
football field you seem very fluent in
French
basically what you say to some other
people seems like you speak French there
Josh am I wrong I know you now try to
start you're not about to start ready so
and I don't speak better you know we
have a good time you have a good time I
feel we play our matches so mom pick up
a few things from those guys and I bring
back wait so when do you think about
football when do you think about it
when do I think about yeah like one does
it
this best every day I wake up big best
for me
um I wake up on it I go to sleep on it
you know I think is the best you always
got working to craft no matter what day
it is
if you sleeping you sleep in your craft
you know you're sleeping about making a
play you sleeping about making an
exception touched on us that's me I
think that as what we do I think it's
become fertile part of us it always has
been that the kitchens been growing
exponentially and being over there
learning a couple of tricks of the trade
about them because their feet work oh my
god is just something like out of a maze
or something it's like a major exciting
you know work their feet and so if I can
take a little tips from them and bring
it back over here and use in my game mmm
so big you know I think I'm always
trying to elevate myself in something
shape form or fashion I think this is
the part of it Josh Norman of the
Washington Redskins joining me here I'll
Shawn Jeffery and Brandon Marshall
joined the divisions Josh do you know
either one of these guys personally
absolutely man we welcome that
competition we welcome that with the
utmost respect because those guys they
can change game in any given moment so
I'm I'm enjoying it I really am I
looking forward to it nothing is better
than the best and that competition is
get it out of yourself
see whether that so it des in the mix -
who's the best wide receiver in the NFC
East do you think I know we got a crazy
prude Casa crew the NFC East I tell ya
that's probably the hardest division
that I've come from will upsell until
one other one entities out and you know
they had a cup of dogs there and who you
are my good you know Brandon cooks when
I use over in the Patriots but when you
look at those guys man every team has
someone so it's not you taking a break
off no you got to play those teams half
of your season you got played up twice
you know so but I play out son Brandon
Marsh and ot not play that guy day is
over there in Dallas so I mean like I
said if we look at our vision that is by
far I think the c'mere
like division for wire receipts so um
when you use a word crew um that's a
boating term is that a reference to
Odell Beckham Josh so what that was I
don't know what kind of rivers that is
you guys take it at so I think you two
get anything you want
now did you just you guys me with the
media did you really just do that no man
I do that but you did that Demetrios me
you just hit me with it
oh you guys look an old person thing
anybody you know what you're right
you're right you're right I'm jabbing
you a little bit you hit me where it
hurt Josh see you are good man you are
good at fun in the weak spot
you're very good day amen think a little
bit and pinch a little bit I'm sorry I
got my little who's that nephew there's
my little nephews in the car comes back
from a chair he's having a nice little
time over there playing with himself how
is he how old's he's good what what Nick
is [ __ ] sure one eight eight months he's
eight months Wow man yeah that's a young
add a month that's young is young and
coming up to be abolished hot well uh
you know surrounded by family and you
know it's a serious question for you
Josh because the conversation in the NFL
last couple of days I don't know if if
you were in Paris or not was about
concussions and Tom Brady's wife saying
that that he suffered them even though I
didn't show up on the injury report and
other other players basically saying
that they have had concussions what what
is the conversation amongst players when
it comes to concussions and reporting
them when they feel that they've
suffered them and it hasn't really been
diagnosed and Emme the culture change
that's required what do you and your
colleagues say about this Josh well you
know I think it's just something that
you know we go through it's definitely
something we go through and I feel like
it's a real notice it is definitely real
um it's something that I feel everyone
has to look at and take it in all
consideration like this serious you know
arm but you can only imagine what
they're the people who had to go through
before all this technology you know the
people
old time like the seventies and sixteen
Union think about the eighties night
they they had concussions I'm pretty
should have much more severe these are
just being reported you know so um this
is serious and I think this is something
that they need to take a look into but
in a day is our profession is that what
we go through it's nothing that we can
afford because of you know the violence
that the sport brings I don't think it's
nothing that we can avoid and unless we
start getting better technology in the
helmet on committee or however that
plays out but this is nothing that's
unavoidable when you looking at another
guy you running straight at them in a
split second you know that decisions
being made you can't hold on you got to
go forward and I mean it's also a spinet
coach so it's a lot of things that go
into place with it and I on just point
flingers like this place or that place
is it's a lot of things you gotta look
at it and that's one of the things I
think
hmm-what because that's that's tough
that's tough do I know
oh we had concussions it seems like you
want to hear something it comes out to
be but they are serious and um they can
set you back for sure
no I mean in that regard what would it
be just in general in in in a locker
room if if one of the guys self reports
during a game and takes himself out
because he thinks he's gotten a
concussion there's five minutes left on
a clock in an important game if not a
playoff game would that be fine in the
locker room with everybody after done
absolutely I mean that's your body
should Hill let's think about this we
playing football for what ten twelve
years if you lucky if your look is great
fifteen I mean come on let's let's be
honest with ourselves
that's a portion of our life that's a
blinking eye you want to live for the
rest of your life in it and live till
you turn 80 I mean shoot those 15 years
and go matter but you want to be healthy
in findell 15 years so you can't live be
eight you know and I think that's the
biggest thing that we look at now
because you have those complications
later on after you done playing that's
when it really hits you so those
concussions are truly all they're
surreal that they're for real and not
in the plate with and not a joke because
your brain is the thing that's going to
last you long as you got to have that oh
yeah
yes that's a real Redskins quarterback
Josh Norman couple more minutes left
with him the owners over the next couple
days think of it taking five minutes off
of the off of the overtime period from
15 minutes to 10 saying that that is a
player safety response what do you say
Josh do you like that idea
10 minutes over 10 15 only I wouldn't
get into all that now I would get into
all that let's that's not continue to
keep changing the game you know I should
always been that way the SOP is this you
try and change the game just because we
say one you know do safety then I can't
I can't see why you would change that me
we know what we get it to be going out
there we plan the game we plan to try to
win we put all our hard our effort into
it and we want to win you taking that
back nobody went in the top nobody in a
stupid time we enter the tower
Cincinnati and shooting taking that tile
away we were one that game then we would
have went to the playoffs but no we Todd
and so therefore we lost the last to it
we lose out to playoffs you know I think
that tires just should be thrown out and
I think you leave that game until that
10 minute mark I mean the extra five
minutes can you know expect the game so
I think that's just leave the game long
where it is is always fun I mean keep
messing with it and problems happens so
I don't know when you back at it with
your teammates the OTAs when ones that
come up this week next week what do you
got yeah this week we got get it
tomorrow I get it tomorrow oh we
cracking it we crack it up tomorrow so
it's gonna be something really cool I'll
see you guys back at it and we've been
working out whole summer so um this
whole offseason so it's gonna be coach
these guys put on some helmets
okay Matt it go out and well Josh I
appreciate the time as always let us
know when you're out here in Los Angeles
okay get your background studio oh yeah
absolutely man you guys always been a
friend so um I appreciate it now that
was a good use of you guys right there
there you go okay that was one that I'll
accept
my marriage right back at you that's a
Josh Norman over the Washington Redskins
at Jay underscore no.24 the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like some of that get some more
of that on the Rich Eisen show lap
follow all the information you see right
here on the Rich Eisen show